make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob
and uh i don't know if we ever really
covered this i mean i guess we kind of
did but if we did do it then it was back
in the day when my video sucked and so
if we did cover it we're gonna remaster
it but we're basically doing the crooked
world story and the reason why we're
doing this
is because of what's going on with ex of
swords and the return of jim jasper's
right there's been a lot of talk
especially in my videos about how
powerful jim jaspers is about what he's
capable of
and how dangerous of a character that he
is but in reality i don't really think a
lot of people are fully aware
of what jim jaspers can do and what
makes him so powerful and really so
dangerous
and this story really covers it now the
other part of why we're doing this is
because this also covers the nature of
saturning right the role she plays and
when she was really kind of first
introduced into marvel comics now a
couple things to understand here
this story the crooked world is was
technically kind of collected into a
more recent seven issue story when i say
recent i mean back in the mid 90s um but
this story was really first launched
when marvel was creating what was called
marvel uk and marvel uk was quite
literally marvel comics attempt to
expand
into the united kingdom and of course
they did it by creating captain britain
the result of this is that you had alan
moore
and alan davis who essentially put this
story together and so
one part of this is kind of a reworking
of the history of
of captain britain in terms of rolling
it more in line with the main marvel
comics universe itself and then the
other part is everything going on in the
crooked world so we're really gonna
really cover the second part here
uh we're gonna kind of skim over a lot
of the stuff like the reworking of his
of his story and his powers and things
like that
because that's not overly important here
right i mean what you know about captain
britain right now in terms of reading
extra swords is all that really matters
when it comes to his character and jim
jasper's is really the main focus here
right so uh this initially picks up with
both
brian brad and captain britain as well
as a character named jackdaw now jackdaw
was
initially introduced in the old captain
britain's stories as essentially a
sidekick right because this was written
back in the 1980s and this was still a
time in comic books where sidekicks were
still a relatively prominent thing
the reality is the sidekicks have kind
of been going the wayside ever since the
1960s right but it took about 20 years
for us to see sidekicks
in a lot of ways beginning to go away a
lot of that was because of batman
because the robin character the robin
archetype was still exceedingly popular
and it really has been
um it's one of those things where i
think publishers outside of dc
kind of failed to understand that the
popularity of robin was because he was
effectively a legacy character
not every sidekick that was out there
was popular or needed to be there and so
jackdaw was actually one of these
characters that was kind of being phased
out at the time this story was being
written the other part of this is that
in the early captain britain stories he
was given a scepter that kind of allowed
him to channel and use his powers
this too is something that was being
removed and that's the reason why
when he sent on this mission to this
alternate reality in earth 238 but not
really given any indication of what the
mission is
once he passes through that dimensional
barrier his costume changes and he loses
his scepter right this is kind of
a really on the nose like this is the
new captain britain now but the idea
here is that once you sit in
this location he immediately stumbles
upon what is in effect a bank heist
right like this this robbery going wrong
now this robbery is being held by a
group called the crazy gang or being
orchestrated by a group called the crazy
gang and captain britain does what he
does right he kind of beats him up a
little bit and says hey you know you
guys need to stop all that kind of stuff
but while all that's going on
jim jasper's is watching it happen and
it's really because the crazy game kind
of seems to be operating at the behest
of jim jasper's right they're basically
his henchmen and they're kind of
carrying out his plot but the the whole
purpose behind this is really just
more for fun and games that what you
have is you have jim jaspers who created
the executioner who has the executioner
here and he's also got the queen of
hearts right so you guys kind of notice
it's very similar to alice in wonderland
in terms of how this goes on and the
result of this is that when he asks the
queen what should we do
her response is off with his head right
and that's when the executioner comes
along and then it leaves captain britain
taking the fight outside now again
jim jasper's is kind of watching all
this unfold right he's watching all this
take place and it's kind of entertained
by it right like this is
kind of interesting right i'm kind of
intrigued by everything i'm seeing he
does of course want to see captain
britain defeated but he is kind of
intrigued here now with this fight
basically getting to the outdoors and
essentially you know the forces of the
crazy game being defeated jim jaspers
gets into his flying teapot and then
basically takes off right he just ends
up escaping
with the crazy gang and that's basically
it right and so you know the dormouse is
the one flying it so you could tell
right off the bat
things were a little wonky here and then
of course captain britain kind of looks
around and it's like none of this really
makes sense like this is kind of
wild i don't really understand this and
he ends up finding a a poster on a wall
that says kind of re-elect the british
national party right which is staunchly
different from what we see in the maine
marvel universe where the british
national party doesn't really exist it's
like a major
figurehead right they're not ruling
anything and so what you end up getting
is is really uh jackdaw and captain
britain kind of going through and
checking out and investigating a few
things
inside of inside of london itself right
to figure out the differences
between the universe they're from and
this place that they're in
now this is when we kind of skim over
stuff and sort of throw in a few little
highlights here and there but for for
most everything else we can kind of blow
it off but one of the big takeaways that
comes out of all this
is that everything really is just
starkly different but everything really
is just staunchly different and they
don't really understand why right
they're not really able to fully grasp
why things are so intriguing here what
you also have are our three major things
that take place
the first is these various you know
homeless people who are out there that
are drinking this alcohol and jackdaw
ends up drinking a little bit of it as
well and it's almost like they have this
kind of mental awakening of how things
truly are now for the most part because
they're homeless and because they're the
outcasts of society nobody takes them
seriously and they consider their
ramblings about how things appear versus
how things really are
to really just be some kind of psychosis
or a drunken stupor or something like
that but the second thing that happens
is there's this giant heap of machinery
that actually just kind of became
sentient more or less and is walking
around
and causing all kinds of chaos now
captain britain responds and ends up
basically kind of defeating this thing
but also drawing the attention of the
military forces that are out there right
or at least
the kind of the kind of paramilitary
forces they're technically uh
individuals that are specialized in
taking on superpowered beings and so
right now we know that like superpowered
beings exist or have existed
in this universe so captain britain's
not the very first one they've ever seen
but he's able to kind of get past these
guys pretty easily and take out the the
junk keep
that walk like a man right so that
happens pretty fast pretty quickly now
these guys who exist out there for the
purpose of taking out superheroes that's
kind of an important thing
those guys specifically are not but the
force they will bring in for the purpose
of taking down superheroes will be
will prove to be exceedingly important
but the other thing that happens is that
once this junk heap is basically
defeated it's just kind of left
and this great big huge you know
crumpled heap that you end up having
captain britain who sort of looks around
for what this stuff is right for like
how it is that this happened and people
are talking about a kind of fluid or
something like that and he stumbles
across this sewer drain
where this sort of you know reddish
fluid is coming out and when he crawls
through the drain and traces it back to
its
energy source or to its to its location
he comes across a
a rat called augernog right he's just
the rat thing right and this is a
walking talking rat who lives in the
sewer and is like you know not super
intelligent but like a human level
intelligence right so like he's
basically a chief sentience and it's
kind of a strange thing because while
that's happening you also have something
called the avant-garde and the
avant-garde
is really kind of introduced to us a
little bit mysteriously we don't really
know much about them all we really know
is they're led by a woman who's referred
to as
herwiness but she starts talking about
this concept of initiating something
called the push and that the rat himself
is the result of the push right which is
to say this chemical that exists that's
kind of being put out there uh this rat
consumed it and that's why it's so
intelligent now
what all that means will come to
fruition exceedingly soon right so i'm
not gonna leave you guys hanging
on why all that's important but what
does matter here is that captain britain
was in effect
an unexpected entity here right he
wasn't really expected to be here and so
what you end up getting is essentially
the avant-garde who kind of step in
for the purpose of detaining captain
britain now he ends up getting the upper
hand on him basically kind of defeating
him to a degree or at least
that seems to be the case but then
ultimately they get the upper hand on
him and the way in which they do this
comes in the form of a kind of
mysterious energy beam this energy meme
is shot at the rat which kind of
devolves him back down into a base level
and then is shot at captain britain
which devolves him back down into a
monkey right and so following that he's
basically captured and taken by the
avant-garde and then in turn
we're properly introduced to saturnine
now saturnine as she's introduced here
and as we're informed by her
it's basically part of a group called
the omniversal development court now
something that i do want to point out
here
is that back then in the 1980s when this
story was written this was done at a
time when the living tribunal was not
something that was constantly invoked
nowadays in marvel comics anything that
really involves the multiverse on a
grand scale the living tribunal pops up
back then
it wasn't really the case the
expectation on the publishing side was
tell the story as if it's in isolation
and introduce new concepts if you can
things that are interesting but don't
use a living tribunal as an easy way out
and that's why we don't really see the
tribunal here
instead what we get in its place is a
creation by alan moore and alan davis
called the omniversal development court
and the way this works is that in every
universe across the multiverse they all
sort of
progress at a particular rate and that
at a particular point in time
certain things are supposed to happen
right so you have what's called
the 50 000 year program which basically
says that at some point we can call this
point zero fifty thousand years from
that point in time
we're supposed to get a kind of
evolutionary process now how this works
in tandem with like the celestials
experimenting on humanity we're not
really given a definitive explanation
here
we can largely kind of make assumptions
that around 50 000 years before this
point in time when superheroes are
supposed to appear
is essentially when modern man became
what it is and we can largely kind of
tie these numbers together and it really
kind of makes sense that about 50
000 years before the emergence of
superheroes is when the celestials
experimented on
early man and so that's why the
omniversal development corps seems to
fall in line with the celestials right
that as part of the celestial's grand
experiment they travel from world to
world
experimenting on the early primitive
versions of his inhabitants and then
basically granting them powers
on earth they did the exact same thing
right on earth they showed up they took
one third of humanity
and then broke that one third into into
thirds itself that one group became the
eternals another group became the
deviants and the third group were
individuals whose powers would manifest
at some future point in time
what seems to happen is the omniversal
development court picks up from there
and they basically make sure that this
evolutionary push which is to say
that the genes manifest so basically we
get like x-men and we get mutants and we
get avengers and fantastic four
that all that stuff happens about 50 000
years after the celestial's first visit
earth and it happens across every single
universe right and so because of that on
this earth there are no superheroes and
that's why
saturnine and the the really her forces
are here is to initiate the push that it
has to be achieved by the year 2000
and that because there are no
superheroes here her assumption
is that superheroes just simply never
evolved right for whatever reason
those genes never really activated and
so the intention here is to initiate the
push
to force those genes to activate to
create superheroes on earth right it's
just what the omniversal development
court does
now when that happens and when captain
britain basically kind of uh is aged
back up to his normal self right when
his uh when his evolution
is kicked back up to where it's supposed
to be he basically really evolves
back into a man this is one part alan
moore and alan davis
giving him like new levels of super
strength and speed and durability things
like that enhancing his powers but it's
also it also allows him to basically
kind of grab saturday right and say like
what's going on here and that's when she
really kind of explains everything that
i just told you guys
in terms of what she does and and all
that kind of stuff but what she also
ends up revealing here
is that their intention is to
essentially take this substance this
liquid that they have
and put it into the water supply and the
water supply you know putting it there
would basically allow people to consume
it and that'll in turn start pushing
them to a higher evolutionary state and
it'll basically allow them to see the
world the way that it really is because
one of the things that's kind of hint
here is that
jim jaspers has kind of used his powers
to distort the way the earth appears as
opposed to the way that it actually is
but the other thing it'll do it'll start
jump starting powers right people will
start getting superpowers and so while
that happens you have essentially
the the status crew that shows up here
and the status crew is kind of a
military group that works for the
government in england and that's kind of
the superhero group
that travels around and like captures
super powered beings or takes them out
basically eliminates superpowered
threats and for the most part they're
all taken out pretty quickly by captain
britain saturnine the avant-garde
those guys are defeated quite handily
but in the middle of all that
these various guys are essentially
splashed with this evolutionary chemical
by captain britain and that's when they
start to realize like they've been used
right their minds have essentially been
tricked and so if telepathy which seems
to be the case has been used by jim
jasper's or at least some kind of
reality warping ability
then in turn it basically takes away
that effect and they start to see the
world the way it is that by virtue of
their actions they've created grave
injustices right like they've oppressed
social classes different things like
that and so realizing the effect that it
has
captain britain basically ends up
traveling out for the purpose of
ensuring that this
uh this liquid is actually put into the
water supply and that everything goes
according to plan now for the most part
it seemingly does right that once this
stuff is put into the water supply and
everything you know
the push begins to happen the various
citizens from across
london start to kind of have this
awakening where they start to realize
okay nothing in this world is the way
that it's supposed to be right like
things are screwed up you know that we
need to focus on making things better
now this is really kind of alan moore
and alan davis sort of criticizing
society at the time
and just kind of being like you know
people need to wake up you know wake up
sheeple you know that kind of a thing
and make the world a better place
but what ends up going on is that while
this huge celebration is happening
and that essentially this will lead to
people developing powers
that during all this time everybody
forgot about jasper's right
everybody forgot about jim jasper's and
so did saturnine or she never considered
him to be important in the first place
because in her mind she never knew
that he was the cause of all this and so
jim jasper's watches all this unfold he
lets them
savor this moment and then he initiates
the jasper's warp and the jasper's warp
literally just starts twisting up
the entirety of reality like it really
just starts warping it twisting it
skewing it turning it inside out the
laws of physics begin to go upside down
so gravity starts pushing away instead
of pulling in
all kinds of crazy things start to pop
off when that happens
nobody in the omniversal development
court knows what's going on and the
biggest fear is that this is a result of
the push that when they did this
they did something wrong that they
screwed something up and they totally
screwed up the world right they
literally
broke the world and so in response to
this uh you know
you basically have the status crew that
shows back up with a being called the
fury and as they describe it the fury
was designed and programmed for the sole
purpose
of killing superheroes right that's its
sole purpose it's basically killing
superheroes and so following that
the the fury literally kind of goes on
the attack and where captain britain
launches an attack against it
nothing happens right i mean this guy
has like this guy has no answer
for the power of the fury and so
saturnine seeing what's going on
grabs the avant-garde and it's like
let's go like i don't know what's going
on in this world but this place is
screwed right i'm just going to get
while the getting is good
and we'll figure out what to do later
and so while that happens the fury just
goes on a rampage and literally just
starts annihilating everybody it kills
jack dock right which is religious them
kind of beginning the process of writing
jackdaw out uh it goes after captain
britain and then of course in the middle
of this whole fight suddenly
jim jasper shows up right in his flying
teapot and rescues captain britain and
this is when we start to get into the
meat and potatoes of what it is
that makes mad jim jaspers so powerful
and so as he's having
you know as he kind of grabs captain
britain and flies away the fury stops
right the fury does nothing it doesn't
go after jim jasper's or anybody and so
from there
jim jasper's kind of starts breaking
down the conversation now once brian
braddock once captain britain gets in
here he immediately knows something's
off
because the inside of this flying teapot
is much bigger than the flying teapot
itself he kind of starts breaking things
down and he says here in this universe
that he's in
that he was a person he was a member of
parliament and that he realized you know
at some point in time he had the ability
to manipulate reality right he had the
ability to control reality
on a universal scale but his powers are
continually growing and so what this
shows is that this version of jasper's
is still
relatively new to his abilities and so
they more or less seem to have just
recently manifested and so in in light
of that and realizing the power that he
possessed
that the wrong move to make would have
just been to distort reality
that the best move to make when it comes
to taking over people is to get them to
believe you
it's one thing to conquer people it's
another to get them to be willing to be
conquered and that's what he was doing
right what he ended up doing was passing
legislation or at least pushing through
the idea of legislation of superhuman
registration saying like we need to
basically get rid of all the superheroes
and because of the fact that he was able
to rally
various human various people to his side
this basically led to him kind of
forcing this legislation through
parliament in response to that he in
turn created the fury and literally just
went through and started killing
everybody like killing all the different
superheroes
now there was a captain britain in this
universe and we'll actually find more
about her
here in a little while but the fury just
in the in a matter of something like uh
two years killed every single superhero
on earth
right everybody on earth now there's a
lot that we're not being told here we're
not being told if the fury killed like
the fantastic four and the x-men and the
avengers marvel uk
was largely kind of a separate imprint
you did see some reprints of of comics
from america
in marvel uk which is them kind of that
was them testing the waters and seeing
if there was an interest there that's
what made captain britain so important
it was the first time that britain
really got from marvel comics
their own character in a series of newly
created stories as opposed to reprints
of old stories right so that's why you
don't really see a lot of other
superhero teams here
because a lot of the emphasis was put
directly on uh on captain britain
because they were trying to push the
idea of a british superhero community
but but brian braddock comes to the
realization
that one jim jaspers created the fury
and programmed it and so the the fury
will basically kill every single
superhero on earth
except for jim jasper's it's just
basically programmed not to and that two
the reason jaspers did this is because
he just wanted to eliminate the
competition he just wanted to be the
most powerful mutant on earth and the
reason why everything
in this reality is so weird and wonky
you have like the crazy gang a lot of
things reminiscent of of like alice in
wonderland then you know all this kind
of crazy stuff that's happening
is because of the fact that jim jasper's
powers are expanding and while he is
able to control them he's experimenting
he's like seeing
he's seeing what he can do how much of
reality he can change
and so as time progresses his hold on
reality becomes stronger and stronger to
the point that he initiated this
jasper's warp and started twisting
everything up
and so what ends up happening is that in
the middle of this conversation that
basically jim jasper's kind of created
illusions of everybody that brian
braddock knows like
like uh like jackdaw of course who's
dead all these people he encountered
like it's really him just screwing with
the mind of of brian braddock and so in
the midst of all this
brian panics and then just out of the uh
out of the the teapot he goes right out
of the flying teapot he goes and he ends
up landing in a cemetery
and then basically he's just kind of
there going nuts right he just kind of
he believes he's actually losing his
mind right and he believes he's been
abandoned by merlin
merlin of course being the person who's
responsible for creating captain britain
and the one who sent him on this mission
uh it's kind of like why did you put me
here right like why have you just
abandoned me in this place
this is and this is insane like there's
no hope for me here and that's
absolutely true right this universe is
beyond saving at this point and so what
you end up getting is a fury who comes
out of nowhere and basically obliterates
captain britain and when that happens
you kind of jump over
to the main marvel universe for a second
and you end up seeing captain uk
and what you find out is that this grave
where captain britain was killed where
brian braddock was killed
and tossed in that grave was meant for
captain uk
the captain uk was the captain britain
from this universe
that when everything popped off and the
fury ended up losing his mind or theory
was kind of sit on this mission
of killing everybody that she basically
abandoned the reality right she she
basically
got out of the earth 238 universe and
then
is essentially a refugee in the main
marvel universe that nobody knew that
she
was there and that she's still
experiencing ptsd and anxiety
from like the whole experience of seeing
everybody that she knows that was killed
and so following that you go into the
resurrection of brian braddock you go
into captain britain who's basically
resurrected by merlin
and is his daughter roma the ones who
are responsible for creating you know
all this captain britain's stuff and
they're kind of we're kind of giving a
little bit of a history there again it's
not overly important they kind of just
so sort of ensure that he remembers
everything that happened and the reason
why is because
sending him to the earth 238 universe
that was a test it was just an
experiment
to see how he would fare against
somebody like jim jasper's and the
reason why
is because the purpose of him being sent
on that mission was not to really defeat
the earth 238 jim jaspers but to prepare
him
for when he faces off against mad jim
jaspers from the main marvel universe
because as powerful as that version of
jim jasper's was from earth 238
that guy is nothing absolutely
nothing in comparison to the power of
mad jim jasper's from the main marvel
universe which is something that we'll
cover in the next video
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end
[Laughter]
if you are new here to commerce explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob fork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you